Traduttore: Claudia Di Lorenzo
Revisore: Isabelle Andrieu
FdB: Katia. KP: Eccomi qua.
FdB: Grandi, veloci cambiamenti.
KP: Velocissimi.
Velocissimi.
E cosa accade agli adolescenti?
Come vivono questa cosa gli adolescenti?
Cosa succede?
KP: Difficile dirlo,
perché solitamente si descrivono
gli adolescenti di oggi in modi opposti.
Si parla degli adolescenti
raccontando soprattutto
i loro aspetti più demotivati,
più superficiali.
Si raccontano - noi li raccontiamo
come ragazzi svogliati, fragili.
Oppure li decantiamo
quando abbiamo in mente
delle straordinarietà,
dei personaggi fuori dalla norma;
e allora ce ne innamoriamo
senza riuscire ad avere una visione
che porti queste specialità all'interno
della grande generazione attuale.
Se dobbiamo invece fare i conti
con le richieste d'aiuto
e con il coinvolgimento dei clinici,
dobbiamo pensare a una generazione
che sostanzialmente è più triste
delle generazioni
di adolescenti precedenti,
è più chiusa,
meno incline ad esprimere
in modo esteriore
la rabbia e l'aggressività.
Quindi sono meno propensi
a lottare, a gridare
e sono più a rischio di chiudersi, invece,
in una chiusura che è un ritiro
dal progetto di crescita.
In una tristezza che li lascia demotivati.
FdB: Forse sarebbe interessante
un esempio, per farci capire.
KP: Credo che l'esempio, gli esempi
che purtroppo molti di noi conoscono,
non solo chi si occupa di clinica,
tra i nostri parenti, cugini, amici,
sono le storie di ragazzi
che in realtà sono stati bambini speciali,
sono bambini che venivano descritti
alle materne e alle elementari come...
...in termini entusiastici.
È quel bambino che è simpatico,
veloce, rapido, sempre in movimento,
con le idee chiare,
che forse si fa fatica
veramente a gestire,
però si intravede che ha un carattere,
che ha una personalità
e che forse è destinato
a non stare nei ranghi,
a non sottomettersi,
e forse sarà anche quello
che riuscirà ad avere,
come dire, la capacità di trovare
una strada meravigliosa.
Ed è un bambino che quando
arriva anche alle elementari,
nonostante dica,
"Io mi occupo di questo,
mi occupo di uccelli.
Voglio occuparmi di animali,
no, solo dinosauri,
no, solo pesci,
questa cosa a me non piace",
questo è un segnale
colto con soddisfazione,
perché vuol dire appunto che le idee
sono chiarissime sin dal principio
ed è in connessione
con le proprie predisposizioni.
Fatto sta che quando si arriva alle medie,
lo sguardo cambia completamente
e quegli stessi elementi
che sono stati utilizzati
e accolti con favore,
stati utilizzati per dire,
"Wow, guarda quante energie,
guarda quante possibilità",
alle medie il registro cambia
e lo sguardo si trasforma,
diventa preoccupato,
diventa allarmato perché,
"Oddio, non sta alle regole.
Oddio, gli abbiamo dato
delle indicazioni e non le segue.
Forse addirittura rimane indietro
nell'apprendimento
proprio perché non è in grado di sfruttare
le tracce utilizzate
già da altri prima di lui".
E quindi quello che era talentuoso
poi diventa allarmato, preoccupato,
a volte anche disgustato,
per cui gli adolescenti
vengono anche visti
con questo tipo di sguardo dagli adulti.
E questi ragazzi che improvvisamente
si scontrano con una visione
che non avrebbero mai sospettato
perché cresciuti invece in anni,
quasi dieci anni, di accoglienza
e di sguardi estremamente positivi,
prime cercano di capire
che cosa è successo,
chi ha sbagliato:
quelli che sono arrivati prima
e che forse hanno visto
un talento che non c'era,
una genialità che non c'era,
o forse hanno sbagliato
quelli che sono arrivati dopo
e che sono ostili agli adolescenti
e che quindi non sono disposti.
Ma sta di fatto che è un quesito
che poi perde rapidamente importanza,
perché ciò che conta
nella mente di questo bambino,
di questi bambini,
è che comunque le cose sono andate storte,
quindi loro sicuramente
hanno sbagliato qualcosa
e quindi possono vergognarsi
per questo atteggiamento
e questa modalità modesta che manifestano,
ma anche questa incapacità
di aver mantenuto le promesse.
Quindi vergogna e colpa si alternano
e a quel punto il dolore è troppo forte,
il futuro non c'è più
e quindi quello che poi succede
è che questi ragazzi si chiudono,
smettono di pensare
che il progetto futuro esista
o che abbia veramente senso.
Si soffre meno a ridurre le aspettative
e a chiudersi in casa,
anche per la paura
di mostrarsi agli altri,
che vedranno le differenze
di quando andavi
alle elementari bello contento
e quando ora invece mostri
in tutta la drammaticità
la tua mediocrità, no?
Quindi un disastro, dal punto di vista
del progetto di crescita.
FdB: Ecco, ma che cosa è andato storto?
Di chi è la responsabilità?
KP: Da un certo punto di vista,
di tutti e di nessuno.
Nel senso che forse
dobbiamo ripartire accettando l'idea
che sia la valutazione positiva
che la valutazione negativa
è nello sguardo di chi guarda
e non nell'individuo che è guardato.
Noi abbiamo un problema molto serio oggi,
noi adulti intendo,
abbiamo un problema molto serio
a modulare i modelli educativi
in modo coerente
tra l'infanzia e l'adolescenza.
Noi siamo gli adulti
che si sentono traditi
perché hanno visto sfumare un futuro...
garantito, mi viene da dire.
Certo, devi fare delle cose
per avere il futuro,
un po' di responsabilità,
un po' di impegno;
però poi quel futuro positivo
non era in discussione.
Oggi invece lo è,
e il futuro che ci aspetta
ci siamo convinti che sia
totalmente distrutto e rovinato.
E siamo anche degli adulti
che hanno sperimentato sulla propria pelle
la drammaticità di insegnare le regole,
a stare nella regola
senza consapevolezza, senza pensiero,
quindi con un pensiero dipendente,
con un pensiero che non ragiona
e non mette in una posizione critica
la regola che ti viene prescritta.
E questo ha determinato un riversamento
di noi adulti sui bambini,
sui piccolissimi,
che dicendo loro
che devono avere coraggio,
che devono essere forti,
che devono cercare rapidamente,
prestissimo i loro talenti
per diventare sé stessi,
per cercare una loro strada,
in modo tale che tutto quello
che poi sarà di difficoltà,
diventerà anche però un qualcosa
che loro sono in grado di superare.
Non abbiamo fatto i conti
con l'adolescenza:
perché l'adolescenza,
rispetto all'infanzia,
mette in campo il diverso,
l'altro, il non conosciuto,
e quindi valorizzare un bambino per noi
che gli stiamo insegnando
la regola nella relazione,
"Fai questo perché io ti voglio bene",
"Fai questo perché io
ho molto investito in te
e io so qual è il tuo bene",
e quindi è una regola che sta all'interno
di un ambiente che conosciamo
e che investiamo di valore
perché ci appartiene;
ma l'adolescente è destinato,
se fa bene il suo mestiere,
ad andare oltre,
ad andare verso lo sconosciuto,
il diverso, l'inesplorato.
E lì noi adulti,
che siamo ancora dentro l'abitudine
a fare i garanti della crescita
perché conosciamo le regole,
conosciamo la responsabilità,
ci spaventiamo e non sappiamo
che pesci pigliare, dovremmo dire.
E a quel punto torniamo
al vecchio modello,
torniamo a chiedergli
di sottomettersi alla regola
in nome della responsabilità,
in nome del diventare adulti.
Gli chiediamo di aderire
al nostro modello:
che abbiamo buttato via,
perché abbiamo visto che non funzionava,
ma non ne abbiamo uno alternativo,
e siamo...
In mancanza di meglio, "chiudiamo"
senza renderci conto che, in questo modo,
chiudiamo la possibilità di creare
una apertura verso il futuro.
FdB: Vista l'esperienza, e la quantità,
di casi che hai analizzato,
hai vissuto e hai aiutato,
che cosa si può fare?
Tante cose fortunatamente,
perché i ragazzi ritirati
sono un numero sempre crescente.
I ritirati sociali sono una quota,
sono quelli che sono chiusi in casa;
ma ci sono sempre più
anche casi di ritiro "mentale",
inteso come un chiudersi e non pensare,
proprio per non sentire il dolore.
Dobbiamo davvero ricominciare
con la consapevolezza
che siamo noi gli attori
che possono spostare l'ago della bilancia.
Il progetto di dare
così tanto valore ai bambini
e poi toglierlo agli adolescenti
immaginando di dare in questo modo
agli adolescenti un po' di prove
in cui rafforzare il carattere,
in cui temprarli,
in realtà è un progetto suicida
per gli adolescenti attuali,
perché vuol dire averli radicati
dentro la relazione, dentro lo sguardo;
e poi improvvisamente,
senza preannunci di nessun tipo,
togliergli quell'appoggio,
togliergli quell'area di solidità
che è la relazione
con gli adulti in generale:
i significativi, ma anche gli insegnanti
e tutti gli adulti che hanno intorno.
E quindi vuol dire consegnarli alla paura,
alla solitudine, alla tristezza.
Poi abbiamo un altro problema serio
che è dato dalla velocità
a cui tu facevi accenno nell'introduzione.
La velocità dei cambiamenti è tale
da avere reso le istituzioni -
Di averle collocate
in una situazione molto difficile,
perché è evidente che oggi noi
la conoscenza la dobbiamo modificare,
dobbiamo considerare una conoscenza
non come l'abbiamo vista noi
e non come l'abbiamo imparata a scuola,
che è una conoscenza fatta di contenuti,
fatta di passaggi lineari,
fatta di rapporti tra chi sa e chi non sa,
chi deve imparare,
che quindi deve ricevere quei contenuti
e deve imparare a ripeterli.
Oggi la conoscenza è evidente
che è una conoscenza processuale,
in cambiamento, in evoluzione.
Ha bisogno di esplorazione,
ha bisogno di menti riflessive,
ha bisogno di menti
che sperimentano la conoscenza.
Ecco che noi siamo ancora collocati
all'interno di un modello,
quei libri alti negli scaffali
di cui si parlava questa mattina,
che non sono in grado, in realtà,
di costruire dei dispositivi
per allenare la mente.
Non si possono allenare
competenze complesse
senza far sporcare le mani ai ragazzi
e quindi senza modificare i dispositivi
e renderli flessibili.
Abbiamo anche un altro problema
che riguarda sempre la conoscenza
per come la immaginiamo noi.
Noi adulti siamo cresciuti -
Dalla rivoluzione tecnologica
della scrittura,
noi abbiamo un rapporto con la conoscenza
che è fatta di nomi,
di definizioni, di casistica,
di inscatolamenti e di analisi
di differenze che ci dicono,
"Abbiamo conosciuto questo concetto".
E questo lo applichiamo a tutto,
anche quando diamo un voto,
quando diamo un giudizio,
quando diamo una diagnosi.
Quindi sia che siamo genitori,
insegnanti, clinici,
in realtà noi applichiamo
una logica tassonomica a questi ragazzi.
Quindi gli diciamo, "Sei così, sei colà.
Prima eri geniale, eri talentuoso;
poi improvvisamente diventi uno
che ci spaventa un po',
che non sta nelle regole.
Forse non riusciamo nei tuoi confronti,
che non sappiamo che cosa stai facendo.
come facciamo a fare noi i garanti
di questo tuo percorso,
che già parla di argomenti, di contenuti
e poi di modalità che non conosciamo".
Ecco che allora gli diamo l'etichetta.
Senza renderci conto
che se l'identità oggi è diventata
un'identità che è in movimento -
si diventa sé stessi,
e ci vuole una vita per diventare
sempre più un po' noi stessi -
abbiamo bisogno di adulti
che si interrogano
sul significato profondo
di quel funzionamento.
Non è l'etichetta che può aiutarci.
Ci serve, dietro l'etichetta,
a ragionare del perché succede questo
e che senso ha,
e quale risorse puoi attivare,
come le hai attivate.
L'ultima cosa, cioè
l'ultima grande tematica,
grande come una casa,
ma bisogna forse provare
a ridircelo tra adulti
prima ancora di coinvolgere i ragazzi,
è che noi in realtà abbiamo condannato
questi ragazzi quando erano bambini
in questo passaggio
dalla famiglia formale,
quella delle regole,
quella dei valori assoluti,
alla famiglia affettiva,
quella delle relazioni,
li abbiamo resi dipendenti
dal nostro sguardo.
Siamo noi che diamo valore,
e infatti quando poi dopo
ci spaventiamo glielo togliamo,
e quindi sono ragazzi
che dipendono profondamente da noi
e dalla nostra felicità, in qualche modo.
Quindi quando noi ci spaventiamo,
noi ci spegniamo,
ci preoccupiamo
e dichiariamo che il futuro
a quel punto è tutto sbagliato,
è tutto perduto.
Questi ragazzi non solo
a quel punto hanno un problema
per la loro sopravvivenza,
ma si sentono anche gravati
della responsabilità
di averci in qualche modo deluso,
di averci danneggiato.
E diventa un meccanismo scisso,
dove tutti i soggetti
sono ognuno da una parte,
in angoscia e in difficoltà.
La stessa, come dire...
L'esempio più eclatante
di questo correre
ai quattro cantoni tutti separati
è l'idea che ai ragazzi noi diamo,
sin da piccoli, dicendo:
"Trova il tuo talento,
trova la tua specialità,
corri, in fretta,
decidi, il prima possibile".
Quel famoso, "Mi occupo
dei dinosauri piuttosto che no",
nell'idea che la tua strada
debba essere concentrata su te stesso,
sulle tue ambizioni
oltre che sulle tue competenze.
In realtà, se quella conoscenza
è una conoscenza che va co-costruita,
va co-sperimentata,
devi necessariamente prevedere
l'esistenza dell'altro,
devi entrare in un progetto
di co-responsabilità della conoscenza.
Tanto è vero che oggi i ragazzi
rinunciano al progetto di crescita,
e rinunciano al progetto di sapere,
se il sapere loro
è a discapito di qualcun altro.
Diventa uno dei fattori di rischio
più alti in una classe,
quando è troppo evidente
che la competizione
privilegerà qualcuno
e toglierà a qualcun altro.
Questo è un elemento che puoi vederlo
nel singolo individuo,
puoi vederlo nel grande gruppo,
perché non è soltanto necessario
a questo punto dire,
"Dobbiamo dare spazio ai giovani,
perché i giovani non è vero
che sono superficiali, incapaci.
Sono invece forti,
hanno le tecnologie in mano,
hanno il loro futuro".
È vero, bisogna partire da lì.
È loro, il futuro.
Il nostro come ce lo immaginavamo
non esiste più.
Ma non possiamo neanche toglierci,
come dire, fare un passo indietro
e lasciare tutto nelle loro mani,
perché sono ragazzi
che abbiamo fatto crescere
nella condivisione,
nella partecipazione nelle emozioni.
Ora bisogna metterci
partecipazione nella costruzione,
non solo della conoscenza,
ma anche del progetto futuro,
perché è come se dovessimo dire,
"Non è più come ci aspettavamo,
è tutto diverso.
Non sappiamo neanche cosa succederà."
Però, se lo facciamo insieme,
qualcosa portiamo a casa.
È come dire che non siamo garanti
di tutto il processo,
ma siamo garanti del fatto
che ne vale la pena
e che insieme possiamo comunque
co-costruire un futuro.
FdB: Bellissimo messaggio.
(Applausi)